And we are recording. Okay.
Hello. My name is Julie Stout.
I it is March 20th, 2026,
and I'm here with Richard Vidutis
It is, around 1 p.m.
eastern time, and I am located
in Bloomington, Indiana. And,
where are you located?
Alexandria, Virginia.
Awesome.
We are here for part
one of our interviews, where I'm going
to dive into your life story
and ask questions about your background
and of the like.
And without further ado,
I can go right into it.
If you're good.
Yeah. Let's go. Awesome.
So my first question for you is,
can you please state your preferred
full name and pronunciation?
Sure.
First name is Richard.
Surname is Vidutis.
It's a Lithuanian name.
Actually, I, I was christened Ričardas
Vidutis. But,
in English,
Ričardas would be Richard.
So I use Richard.
Great.
Well, I think you.
Do the number by by myself.
Or do you want to?
Oh, you do that one more time.
But do you want to ask me
these questions or.
Yeah, I will, yeah,
I can ask you these questions.
Okay. Yeah.
So my next one for you is
how old are you today?
And what is your date of birth?
I'm 80 today, and I was born on June
11th, 1945.
Can you tell me where you were
born as well?
I was born in Regensburg, Germany.
Oh, sorry.
Could you say that one more time for me?
Regensburg, Germany.
Oh, Germany.
So diving into your family life
and childhood.
Next. Can you tell me a little bit
about your parents
or guardians and their occupations?
And if you have any siblings? As well.
I'm an only
child, and my parents are from Lithuania.
The refugees from World War two.
We came over here in 1949,
to Gary, Indiana,
and we've been there since,
Why did they move to, Gary, Indiana?
My father found a sponsor,
a distant relative.
We sponsor this to come over.
Western Europe had millions of refugees,
who are seeking to be resettled.
And then my father found a distant
relative who's for service,
to come to Gary.
And that's where my parents stayed
until they retired.
And then they moved to Florida.
What was your experience
growing up in Gary, Indiana?
Well, it's kind of complicated.
Gary was at that time,
a very multicultural, very ethnic 70,
that had a very good economy
and a good economy
based on the steel industry.
And, that's
what brought a lot of people to Gary.
But starting in about the 1970s, the
economy started to collapse and the city,
started to decay and disintegrate.
And today,
I think it's like 25%, abandoned.
So but at that time,
there were a lot of people who were there.
It was called the 20th Century City.
It was actually built by U.S. steel.
You know,
I think it was the first Plant City
or 20th century,
so there were a lot of people there,
a lot of ethnics, especially,
not just Europe, a lot from Europe,
but also a big, black migration
from America.
South.
And they were all there
mingling together in the mills.
So it was kind of a very interesting
community.
Hundreds of different languages
spoken, different cultures different
or those ethnic organizations.
So that was the sort of the landscape
that I grew up in.
But the cultural landscape.
So it was like a melting pot in a way.
In a way, yeah.
Melting pot.
Somebody else
describe it as a salad bowl, but. Oh,
like all mixed together.
Yeah.
But still retaining their individual,
Vegetable
characteristics
like their own like identity.
So and everything
the area that you lived in in particular
were there other like Lithuanian refugees
living there as well.
Or was it the city.
There was an area,
13th and Grant,
where there seem to have been
a lot of lost wages, but there was also
a Lithuanian Catholic parish
that was founded,
I think, in the early 1900s.
And it in essence was, well,
it was the church,
but it also had a school,
and it became kind of,
like a community center for the community.
And that's where I went to school.
I went to, Catholic school taught by nuns.
And then after that, I went to, Andrean
High School,
which was I was in the first class
of the new building.
So not that,
it was taught by nuns and priests
or I had priests or teachers.
Would you say you.
So, are you a practicing Catholic today?
No, no.
What was your experience with in school,
then?
Favorite subjects? Favorite teachers?
The people that you were with,
It was not a very good education.
It was basically based on,
sort of Catholic morality.
It was just a lot of lecturing
about religious matters.
We were very disappointed as kids
because that was,
started
what was called the space age, where,
the first satellite, Sputnik.
The Russians set the spirit
in the center of the space.
There were all this, rocketry with,
the Defense Department.
So it was this.
I see it as the beginning
of this technology, technological age.
We're still learning today.
And we were very excited about it.
And we actually tried to read up
on buying all kinds of magazines,
even in grade school, you know?
So education and all that was
very important, even at that early age.
We we wanted very much
to get out of that great school
and get to a better education.
So did you have an interest
in like, science and space yourself or,
was I just like a product of the time
and everything?
Yeah.
I mean, I did very much and to this day,
I really like
reading about science and technology.
What did you go to for school?
After your high school?
I went to
Indiana University with the intention
of becoming an astronomer,
which didn't work out
because I was not good at math,
but, eventually,
I settled on Slavic studies,
Slavic languages.
It took,
Russian, Polish and,
along with German,
I think because of where
I grew up in, Gary,
I was so interested in languages.
Even in high school,
I took, Spanish and Latin,
and then and, and I you
which were was related to, to the U.S.
Army, language school
to this very day in the university
has a very,
great,
well,
many courses in many different languages.
And I took advantage of that,
studying Slavic.
And then,
I spent the year in Poland in person.
I said, I'm at school at university.
And then eventually,
and that up in grad school
and in the folklore department,
actually
interested
in more sort of holistic ethnography.
But it's not just the folklore.
I also took more languages.
I was involved in,
and the really county
Department of semiotics, such a,
so that was sort of my experience.
And, you.
Do you think that your family background
led you to want to study like,
Slavic languages and get into that
cultural, like side of your studies?
Yeah.
I, my parents were like,
you know, trilingual in all languages,
and everybody around me,
in the city was like a private,
for example, this is sort of,
but I think it's pretty good.
Example
where we lived on Harrison Boulevard.
I could almost remember every house
on our side of the street,
except for two.
And they each one
was a different ethnic group.
But I can remember it was Serbian, Slavic,
Lithuanian, Italian.
I don't remember the Lithuanian,
I don't remember Mexican, Slovak.
Everybody on our street was an immigrant.
And that whole area of Gary and,
later I found out
it's called the Hungarian region.
I didn't know that.
So that just gives you kind of a snapshot
of what Gary was like at that time.
Going
into your cultural
and linguistic traditions at home,
what languages did you speak at home,
and are there any traditions
or practices that you can think of that
your family practiced, like with you?
We never spoke English at home.
I was always Lithuanian. And,
I think I was,
I was pretty American, except for,
one holiday, which was Christmasy,
which was a very important
for Lithuanians.
The other big one was, Thanksgiving.
This is my mother called it Turkey Day.
So those two really stand out.
But everything else was just,
you know, normal American.
That Friday.
Friday's
used to be also kind of interesting.
Every bar in the region would,
people go there to get, lake perch,
coleslaw, lake perch, some fries and beer.
And that was kind of a tradition
for a lot of people.
And was that like,
the whole community came together
to celebrate together
or like, individual family units did this?
The Christmas Eve was a very much
a family, tradition
of friends might come over,
but each family
tried to have their own.
So I know that you touched on this
already a bit, but just you,
go into
the specific cultural background questions
which cultural or ethnic heritages
do you identify with,
and has your self-identification
changed over time?
No, I mean, it's pretty much,
I'm kind of, you know, I think
what's what kind of person meaning one
part is ethnic, the other was American.
So a combination of
those things,
I think a lot of
that's like people feel the same,
you know, the
they're Americans,
but they also have an ethnic
background. So.
Did you feel close
to your Lithuanian heritage
growing up, or did you,
because you basically grew up here
in the United States,
was is that mostly what formed
your identity over time?
Yeah, I feel close to it.
I mean, the kids of,
emigres or refugees like my parents.
One of the things that was
happening back in Europe,
this was postwar.
My parents fled.
What exactly what is happening
today in Ukraine?
It was it was really horrible. And,
my uncle, for example,
my father's brother,
I don't know why,
but they decided to stay, and they were
they were, deported to Siberia
for ten years.
On death trains or people freeze.
I mean, horrible stories
and Lithuania alone.
And I'm not talking about other countries
like Belarus.
So a lot to your story.
It was the when you are alone,
the estimates are between
100 and maybe 300,000
people were deported.
Siberia, at least 60,000 died.
And so when these,
refugees, like my parents
escaped, they brought with them
the idea that one day they will go back.
And so they fled for their culture.
You know, they supported the,
the Lithuanian parachute,
where everybody would meet for celebrate
the first independence and, other kind of,
they would teacher, for example,
I went there to Saturday school
to, to keep, my Lithuania up.
We learned how to dance and sing,
you know, of the Lithuanian, songs.
And these parishes
were all through Carry On.
It was just Lithuanian.
They all did pretty much same thing.
They wanted to keep alive their culture
within the American landscape.
So. Did you enjoy this?
These, like, Saturday school sessions
to, like, get in touch with your culture?
Or were you really young
and did it help me understand?
I thought it was cool,
you know? Yeah. Different.
Yeah.
Same time.
Also,
the anti-immigrant, feeling was always
there.
Just just as we see today.
The maligning of
immigrants by, you know, by MAGA Trump
that's always been there.
My earliest feelings, and I don't,
I don't know where they're coming from,
but somehow I'm being told
that I'm different.
I'm not right.
There's something wrong with me.
I've always felt that, you know, with.
But that's American.
I mean, it has a long history
of immigrants coming here.
And they're told they need to assimilate,
through my career of doing various
kind of cultural projects.
I don't know how many people have
never told me the story that,
my parents
didn't want me to learn the language
because they wanted me to be successful.
Meaning hide your ethnic identity.
So for a lot of people,
it was a rejection of the old countries.
For some of us,
we rejoiced
what we had from the old country.
What I never left, I was never born there.
I was never left.
But I grew up with the idea of returning
just really weird.
And so eventually I sort of did.
I went there a couple times,
and now my wife is from Lithuania,
so we go back
every once in a while.
You just answer
my next question,
which was, have you gone back
and what was your feeling
when you went back?
Did you?
Yeah. Let me know what you were feeling.
Well, it was
it was really a special moment
because I spent a year in Poland,
which is right next to Lithuania.
And then, I was happy
because of all this Russification.
It was a,
you know, just a brutal dictatorship.
But I
braved myself and got a visa to Lithuania.
It was limited to three days.
By then, my uncle and his family,
had come back to the winter from Siberia.
So I was going to be the first person
to meet them.
That was really an emotional moment.
Oh, excuse me.
Did you meet any of your other family
that so lives and so.
Yeah. So I met them.
I was the first one to meet them.
Now, was this really, great moment.
But then later on,
a few years later,
things improved a lot in Lithuania. And,
I got a summer scholarship
to Venice University and was like,
So I spent the summer at the University,
with another project in mind.
But anyway, so I got to see with the
when you're doing so very well today,
30 years later,
it's totally different.
Culture and country.
About how many times
have you been able to visit,
if you can remember.
About,
I guess 5 or 6 times.
Yeah.
Were you able to ever
go back with your parents at all?
No. Unfortunately,
my parents died before that happened.
But my mother didn't see that in 1990
was when,
gained that second independence.
It was the first republic
from the Soviet Union to,
declare its independence.
It must have been wonderful for her
to see that before
sadly passed. Then.
But the war, you know, disintegrated.
Our families, I have relatives.
Well, I had them in Chicago and Montreal
and Australia and Poland.
Everybody just
they were all refugees
and they ended up in different places.
I know that there's a huge
Polish and Lithuanian population
in Chicago like you just mentioned.
Right.
And I grew up in the Chicagoland area.
And. Actually part. What.
What part?
The northwest suburbs.
So about an hour from the Wisconsin border
or so,
and my own heritage
as Polish and Lithuanian.
And so there's like a yeah.
So there's like a whole area
there as well.
You know, you remember the surnames.
So I think we could discuss that
more after.
I'm so sorry.
But I'm also adopted as well.
Long story short. And so,
I know by my dad's name was two,
and he was from Poland.
And my mom's name was, Reed.
Christina Reed.
And she was.
My dad was the mostly Polish one.
He was from. Poland. So. Yeah.
But going back to you, I'm so sorry.
I. That's
what I was going to ask your, summers
you went to.
You did, like, a summer program
in Lithuania.
I believe you said. Yeah.
What was the program for?
They try to bring back
kids from,
school, from around the world.
So from parents
who had emigrated at one point or another.
So our group had,
people from Latin America,
from all over Europe.
From the US, of course.
So it was a collection of different kids
from different countries.
And then they basically.
Was just to get to know this woman here.
We had really interesting,
courses.
We toured the country,
but I also had another
intention that I was going to do
my dissertation on a topic
that didn't work out of school,
and I thought I would try to see if
that they would allow us see the materials
in Lithuania, but they wouldn't
because it was too nationalistic,
would have been to enter Russian.
So they didn't let me.
But I had already by then, a scholarship
to a research scholarship to Finland to,
during
the first independence of the
when our new,
of our friends Finland's, activities
and trying to keep their culture alive.
And so Lithuania
asked for help and this one guy,
I will see that Naomi came
and helped Lithuanian.
So to somehow introduce their folkloric
traditions and to educational materials.
And that's the stuff I wanted to look at.
I knew it was in, in Helsinki
when I even visited Helsinki,
the winter before to find out
what the materials were.
Unfortunately,
there was a big renovation going on
and we couldn't get to see
them, but I was assured that
it would be there.
So I got the Finnish government
scholarship to go there.
I got to Finland
and it turned out during the six months
that somebody from Lithuania came
and took all those materials.
And so when I was in Lithuania
at that time, those materials over there.
But they wouldn't tell me because I guess
they thought they couldn't.
It would have been too much.
It's a Russian if I, sort of researching
Lithuanian nationalist documents,
you know, that was
it was really weird. But,
anyway,
kind of an interesting story.
So the Lithuanian documents
were in Finland.
I thought they were.
They totally reassured me.
But during, Yeah,
I was there for Christmas and
and and the,
the summer program started by then.
Somebody came from
Lithuania, I think it was,
folklorist, a professor somewhere else.
So I'm not sure he took the stuff
back to Vilnius,
and, it got to someone,
and I guess he was.
I'm sorry,
I don't know. This is a big mess.
Materials gone, but they were in Lithuania
when I was there,
but they wouldn't tell me it was.
And it was crazy.
But you wanted to do your original
dissertation on Lithuanian folklore.
Essentially. Yeah.
And how about Lithuanians
use it in their education?
Department.
You know, teach children
because they had been under
the Russian Empire for so long.
You know, it was, sort of,
that they kept their culture alive,
sort of under the table.
You can.
So anyway, this was a big deal for.
But you weren't able to fully
research, due to the time
period under the.
I could.
I couldn't yeah. It's just, a good time.
It's similar to that. Was it? Yeah.
What did you, switch your studies to then
since you couldn't fully dive
into the other one?
Well,
to make a long story short, eventually,
Richard March, told me to come to Milwaukee.
There was a community center there.
He was working there,
to work there, too.
And so I went there.
And the curious thing was,
the head of that community center was,
But you could call a prima a madam.
He was a until I.
Oh, that's the Richard March
with so much of what happened.
But he fired everybody.
And so I was took
I was stuck in Milwaukee.
I don't know what to do.
I did a project
for the American Folklife Center
on Latvian Saturday School.
And then one day, the local Finnish
foundation had, a gathering.
So I went to it and there was a guy there
showing slides of
Finnish farmsteads
and Michigan's Upper Peninsula.
I asked them if you need any help, and
he hired me for the summer to go up there
to, document and farms
that did that and realized that
this area was so rich
and vernacular
architecture
that I decided to do my dissertation.
So that's where I stayed.
A total of about 13 months.
And I went to over a hundred for us
that got about like 3 or 4000 photos.
Some measurements and everything.
So that's that was my dissertation.
And that was in Milwaukee in.
It was in Milwaukee, for. Sure.
In Milwaukee. Yeah.
And, that show me
when I lived in the Baraga
area of the Upper Peninsula.
Yeah.
I was I had the pleasure
of speaking with Richard March,
not not too long ago.
And hearing your story and his story,
they're a bit similar, would you say,
would you agree?
It would.
Look, you know, a lot more more about it
because he was there earlier.
Longer. Right.
I was just there
for a short time,
and I just everything fell apart.
Could.
Because I know that he was talking
about growing up in a Croatian
like household.
And it's not dissimilar to you
growing up in your Lithuanian,
household with your parents.
And he was also drawn
to kind of studying his homeland, per se.
That's what that's what, you're sorry
also reminds me of that as well.
Yeah.
If you would agree.
So we talked a little bit about your,
migration story.
So I'm going to move on
to this next question,
which is about something on the lighter
end, which is about your like
celebrations and holidays, which I know
you talked about a couple of them.
I'm curious about foodways,
if you grew up with certain foods
and also what like everyday practices
were,
were common in your
community, in your family?
Yeah.
My parents are very conservative
culturally.
Not politically,
but culturally very conservative.
Like I said, we only spoke with them
and my mother
did most of the cooking. And,
a lot of soups, a lot of,
which you might know is Catawba,
we call them
called do like,
a lot of different soups.
I mean, just kind of,
if, you know, Polish,
corn, it's very similar.
So we never, I think
through all the years, I think we went to
a restaurant twice,
just never went to a restaurant.
It was always. It's always cooked.
Yeah, always.
Did you did you learn from your mom?
Did you pick up anything yourself?
Yeah, yeah I did.
I mean, I'm interested in it.
I even did an article for
Lucy Long put on an ethnic.
What did she call it?
Encyclopedia or something.
So I contributed, one on Lithuanian foods.
And I follow it.
There's a professor in Lithuania
who's a outstanding
in his knowledge
of the history of Lithuania.
Lithuania is is it
interesting area in Europe is crossroads.
Every conceivable army had marched
through the east, west, north, south.
So it's just got all kinds of different,
influences from different groups.
So I've always been interested in that.
And even, when my kids come around,
they'll try to make some ethnic dishes.
This, to remind them.
Do you cook with your,
wife as well, since she's also Lithuanian?
Yeah.
How did you,
did you try to impart these traditions
and practices onto your kids as well?
Like, do they know Lithuanian?
Do they know the food or, the culture?
My daughter is trying to
raise her two kids.
Oh, she,
speaks Lithuanian.
So because she's there
listening to this, as good as mine.
But anyway, so impressive
that she's trying to do that.
Yeah.
So it's, less fluent,
but they're more than just in
a, you know, it's hard to maintain
that when the whole surrounding
is English all the time.
So, you know, they you see.
That's exactly what I was thinking
when I asked
that question was how, how, if at all,
were you able to preserve that?
Because I know
it can be really difficult to do so.
Well in our, in this,
age of technology, you know, the,
I get Lithuanian to ten bucks a month
so I can watch all kinds of programs
and movies.
Just utterly amazing.
They can keep it up.
Oh. That's possible.
And then travel.
You can travel there all the time.
So it wasn't like back in my day
where I was just in the family,
and that was it.
And among friends.
Were you able to travel to Lithuania
with your kids as well?
No, not yeah, we were thinking about it.
Oh. For the future.
So maybe my my daughter goes there.
She's looking for,
summer camp for,
her son is three years old now.
Oh. Or
and but I don't know, she,
she can make it.
They just bought a house
and finances are crazy.
That's very fair.
It's exciting that you might be able
to do it in the future, though.
Fully.
I think it would be really cool.
Yeah.
A very, like,
full circle moment, I think, as well.
Bridging your
upbringing and passing it on and,
and also your grandson
to potentially see things as well.
Yeah. No.
So moving on to my next question,
if that's okay with you.
I know you mentioned that you went to
Catholic schools growing up, correct?
Yeah.
Did you practice any other,
religious or spiritual like traditions
as part of your upbringing
and how did they influence your values
and daily life?
And of course, you can share
whatever you feel comfortable with.
No, it's just
I was an altar boy for me, but,
just a regular Catholic.
Religion.
We had that church
was an altar boy.
I think that's
what got me interested in Latin.
That's why I took it.
And then I school. But other than that,
nothing
extraordinary.
That's right.
This one's kind of a fun one,
but what community spaces
or organizations, were central to you,
whether it be clubs,
cultural centers, congregations,
or neighborhoods?
Other than the parish.
I went to the YMCA a few times.
Other than that, nothing really.
We were a wild bunch of kids.
I mean, everybody grew up.
I grew up in the alleys.
That's
where we always played and gathered.
Other than that,
I didn't know there was nothing
beyond the parish church.
What were your like?
Who were your childhood friends like?
What was it like growing up with them?
Yeah. That's interesting.
Even though it was on the way and parish,
the school
and everybody in there,
I mean, my closest,
most, most of my friends
growing up are Mexicans.
I only had like one Lithuanian friend.
The other two were served in a slower,
so the parish itself
was shaped,
though there were blacks in Washington.
I mean, there was something in there
in that school, even though it was
Lithuanian, quote unquote,
Puerto Rican peoples,
for some reason,
Mexicans were my closest friends. And,
that's why I, I think Spanish also.
There's that salad bowl
analogy kind of comes into play again,
with the people that you were surrounded
with and grew up with as well.
Yeah.
You noted a bit on how,
there are still discourse from people
who thought that you didn't belong
or should go back to your country,
along those sentiments.
And I was wondering if you can
recall experiences of inclusion, exclusion
or cultural exchange in Bloomington
or in Gary, where you grew up?
Well, I
mean, that feeling that I had
from the very beginning,
it was interesting.
I think I was like an outsider
for from day one.
I love the watching people and seeing
how they behave. The,
So you have these this really dense ethnic
community of Gary and
eventually I see people breaking up that
trying to exit their ethnic community
and become Anglo, whatever that means.
They stop, even,
as children, I am where they.
There was some kids who, like,
didn't want to deal with us anymore.
They had their own group,
which were not ethnic.
But it's funny to see it happening
such an early age.
Apart from that.
I don't know,
I mean, everywhere I look,
I was thinking about this the other day.
Everywhere I lived,
it was sort of a repeat of Gary,
and I never really thought about it
consciously that a couple months ago
that,
like, now within here,
this part of of, Alexandria,
I think this is a muslim area.
There are so many horrible
stores, Mediterranean
store,
our apartment block,
you know, the women with, the,
so I forget the coverings, you know, like,
you see it on the list.
So I've always lived in areas
that were heavily ethnic,
never even in Bloomington.
It's funny, because the first year
when I went to Bloomington,
it sounds crazy,
but I never get parts before.
And or, like,
my, dorm mates
were, from southern Indiana,
and they all thought because
I was from Gary, that I was a gangster.
Because of, the reputation.
And Gary has a reputation.
Almost from day one,
I was reading a WPA publication
where they talked about that area,
Chicago, where it had become a big city,
and the northwest Indiana was just,
doing some swaps.
And that's what a lot of,
crooks used to hang out
to escape from Chicago police
that's maintained their reputation
to this day.
It's just really interesting.
So, yeah, crime was a big deal, but,
other than that, I think where we were,
we saw the divisions,
but we were proud of what
we were.
It's almost it's
it's a weird problem in America.
There are some people here.
Lots,
because of their Anglo background.
They think their core culture
that we all should just leave.
So maybe we're.
Would you be able to speak more
on the reputation of Gary
and how people perceived it.
About the wedding.
Reputation of Gary
and how people perceived it?
But I think the age group,
like my parents
who didn't want to work in Mills,
but my mother was a midwife,
and my father worked in the government,
but they had no choice.
And my father ended up
and he was still for over 20 years.
And my mother became a seamstress.
Nobody really liked the jobs
they were doing,
but, in part because area was polluted,
heavily polluted.
A lot of the job itself was just
very dangerous.
The pollution was horrible.
And so I, you know,
so I used to work the 2 or 3 summers.
So I don't think anybody really liked it
except that
for a short time
after the war, you couldn't be real,
make really good money.
Asia and Europe were destroyed.
They needed steel to rebuild,
and there was providing it.
So people were working double shifts
so that they were making good money until
Europe rebuilt, Asia rebuilt.
And then, they didn't need Korean anymore.
But at us.
Okay, like I said, it
worked there in the summers.
And for some reason, U.S.
steel hired a lot of college kids.
I don't know about, like, tax rates
and I don't know, but,
you know, we went there to work,
but we hated it.
And I would like, take some
some of it or put it on a small jar.
Take that bloomington's to remind me
of what I want to get away from.
So a lot of people are just, like,
especially young people would just,
you know, working their way out of Gary.
Well,
also, it was like a, cultural wasteland.
I mean, there was very little there,
except for the Palace Theater,
which had three massive names.
But at that age,
they big stars would show up in the area
like Frank Sinatra and other stars.
But, other than that, if you wanted
really good culture
like the museums, if you went to Chicago,
it was like 30, 45 miles away.
Much closer
than I actually thought it was.
Chicago or approximately.
Yeah, yeah.
And when you drive,
let's say starting in Gary,
there are no breaks.
You never know
which city or, Gary Hammond.
Whiting, South Chicago.
Just get on, 41.
You can go off from Gary
all the way to the Upper Peninsula,
but when you're driving up
to the northwest Indiana, Chicago,
there are no breaks anywhere.
You never know where you are exactly
what? What?
I definitely understand that,
can you walk me
through the places
that you've lived in line with,
like, your life, whether that be career
or relationship or personal?
Trying to get a timeline of.
You grew up in Gary.
Went to IU in Bloomington.
What were the next steps
after you graduated from your program?
Okay, so I was born in Reagan Burg.
I don't know how long we were there,
but then.
We then,
for about four years,
we lived in Seinfeld,
which is, on the Larry and,
little village and southern Germany.
From there we went to carry and,
so I went to, you know,
sort of school and then
to Bloomington,
and to Porsche nine point.
Do you remember
the years that you were in undergrad,
through graduate
and, Bloomington?
What's,
what's in the 70s?
When?
Except guess I really bad. It
years.
So, trying to pull up my resume because,
So anyway, so
it was in, like, starting in the 60s,
and then I was,
I was
this is the Vietnam era,
so I was so drafted,
I didn't end up in Vietnam, but, so
what was it for Falcon?
What we sat for for the hood in Texas.
It was not a very good student.
And that experience of,
Really shook me up for.
A change somehow
I became a really good student after that.
Starting, I do,
and then.
But anyway,
so then I saw some of these, scholarships
a little bit closer to home,
which is on the western wall. And,
so I got up.
Another one was in Iraq
and then in Helsinki.
Was that was that when you lived there
during your dissertation writing,
or was I after or.
I think I was still searching
about what to do.
I almost did my dissertation
on, when I was in Bloomington.
I started doing a project
at Dubois County.
Okay.
Along the Ohio River. There's a,
a small
Catholic, German Catholic
village called folder,
and they had this really cool cemetery.
A lot of the
the markers were,
I mean, really folk. And,
and a lot of iron crosses.
So I almost did my dissertation on that,
but it didn't work out.
Which is a good thing,
I think, because it's kind of,
but what can you do with a degree
in cemeteries?
I don't know, so,
so then I come back
and I'm a little mean to.
And sometime
my parents had moved to Florida,
so I stayed with them for a while.
Financially.
And just the dissertation
ended up in the DC area.
So you finish your dissertation
in Bloomington,
and then you lived with your parents
in Florida, and then you moved to
Bloomington.
Also, I it the
conditions and the other
I mean, this is what it
what happened
the sky hired me for the summer
and they said,
I'll give you a free place to live.
And I thought, wow, that's cool.
What they were they were joking with me.
The free place to live
was on an abandoned farm
in the middle of the forest, and
the closest neighbor was over a mile away.
I was I was there with nothing.
No electricity,
no water, no phone, no nothing.
Except in this cabin
where they had dragged them
from another town and,
But I loved it.
I loved every second of it.
And I was coming out of the urban areas
straight into
a wilderness, some general wilderness.
And I just loved it.
And that's why
I really learned how to do fieldwork
and especially approach people in the
that kind of field work
to communicate. So,
the Gary Project was,
I never have done any kind of fieldwork
before.
The area projects.
So to me, it was an eye opener.
And there was a first time
when dealing with strangers and,
how to communicate with them
that that sort of stuff,
was pretty scary
at first and started doing it.
But, so I was grateful for that.
And Gary Project kind of, started
open me up to the field works,
of which I love doing field work.
Know I could do it all the time.
Did you go to school
thinking that you would be a
like an academic or a professor,
or what was like your dream?
I guess
I didn't quite understand,
but really, I mean,
my experience of folk
was not very low career,
which means that I've done
I don't know how many projects
all over the country just, you know,
being employed.
So I didn't know.
But now I can see the
the academic program is basically
to prepare professors,
you know, the academics because,
when I was there in, in Bloomington
in the,
they didn't really teach field work.
I mean, what they there was some kind of,
couple days we were out in Dubois County.
I mean, it was just ridiculous.
So when it showed up in somebody's house,
there are like ten of us,
all of us with a cassette recorder.
And the person almost freaked out.
But there was just, you know,
you know, like, how to do field work,
how to use equipment, how to set a camera,
a recorder, you take down that,
how do you deal with data?
How do you,
You know, analyze it.
It just wasn't there.
So you had to seek it out yourself.
And I was so
that was hard.
And even people who
I wish gave me some guidance
and really know what to do,
and this was basically
documenting
multi sites
with some multi artifacts on it.
Even though it was there
and Roberts
was there and somehow it was weird.
But then I realized that academics
really don't do much field work like
I want to do Dawson's Creek again.
I hadn't looked at it for decades.
And so they're only done fieldwork
in three places
Maine, the Delta and the U.P.
and I think the project,
the Carey Project,
he was really looking forward to it
because this was a chance
to do some deep field work.
But I think that might be a problem
with a lot of academics,
even though they're really good,
really deep experts.
But it's not broad.
I mean, not many subjects.
Because a lot of focus,
you're training on doing something,
and their data
don't end up in academia.
I don't know.
It's really under.
But, do field work in the public sector.
Really?
I think the thing that we've come across,
it's really,
we go ahead
and a collection and analysis and,
preservation. So.
But, it was interesting
going from Dawson's book.
A lot of people
didn't like it or something
because he's basically a historian,
and he was really interested
in a history of folklore.
But that's one of my pet peeves today
is that, the folklore is just,
chapter oriented, you know, colored
narrative with, that's something
with not too much context,
and land on a map of rats.
Dawson, sometimes it goes.
It's such deep detail about the site.
I didn't notice that before.
And that's what I think is missing in,
outside academic folklore.
So what did you do after you
graduated, then?
What career did you go into?
Well, I looked for jobs, and then I did,
a lot of,
Sort of the,
I mean, all over the place,
from California, which involves, like,
20 different projects,
service, cultural surveys.
So you had, like, contract.
Contract work?
Yeah.
Basically.
Just parks or the Park Service was,
was fantastic.
It's the best you'll work,
I think you'll ever do is for them.
You have, like, three months
to do extensive research and write up.
That's absolutely fantastic. Okay.
I worked for over a
little bit over a year for them.
And what else?
The Florida Bureau of Historic
Preservation of Catholicism was there,
and we did a survey
of checking architecture, workers
etiquette, texture,
and Chicago.
That was,
oh, it's called Urban Traditions.
So, yeah.
But I can remember that
also, during that time,
it was a really big community time.
They had all kinds of festivals.
So I think it was going on. So it,
the social.
Well,
also not you
was all the other big project,
the Hungarian project.
Is that was Linda dig.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
And I was well into to,
So I was sort of like the field
skilled manager
for something who kept tabs on the guys
on here in Washington
for photographic
survey of the fish market.
In Milwaukee, when I was there, the,
lottery and Saturday school
for the Smithsonian here,
I did a a survey on the Virginia
horse culture.
I okay.
Maryland.
I work for the historical society
canvased the whole state
looking for some kind of workers
who present their stories.
You read, I was going to say. So.
It seems like you made field work.
Your actual career
in all these different positions.
Yeah.
And I eventually got
that, ended up with FEMA,
starting with, Hurricane Katrina,
which is a very interesting story.
That really made me angry.
I got hired as an, as I refer
to make a really long story short,
I tried to involve people.
I got to go.
Oh, it's perfect.
Perfect example of these federal programs
that don't employ.
It's not refers
as a as a concept as part of their teams.
I gave up on that though, and
I think it was this I was made,
in charge of the American.
So she declined to work with archeologists
because they were structured,
and that could open the door for her
to be in every company in the country,
be part of the,
whatever narrative
comes out of her project,
they would have had their say.
Today.
It's just archeologists, stories
we make all the.
Observations.
And it's just really sad.
But anyway, which just
part of
so I mean,
but half a year ago, I was in Iowa,
the Midwest up there as these storms
sometimes just really stuck with.
So, part of this, division called
Environmental Historic Preservation,
where we try to,
preserve, you know, cultural places.
Do you have a most memorable job
that you took on or impactful for you?
To possibly the, you know, the first one
I did for the Park Service,
which was in the RV desert,
which I'm sure a tree.
And I just loved it.
I fell in love
with the whole concept, the desert.
I mean, I've never experienced
anything like it.
And again, it was so
an example.
How the federal government works and.
I don't know if they consciously
tried to stay away from people or what.
So, that's an element that's
often becomes
irritating to people for some reason.
But I fell in love with the desert
and I did another project there,
which was,
that's another field of the ranch
in the middle of the desert.
And that was really cool.
I really enjoyed that.
And somehow along the line, I've become an
expert on historical bridges.
I didn't like animal rights all
42 reports in Pennsylvania, and I.
Like Lake Wales,
they're trying to destroy Thema,
so I don't know what's going to happen.
What drew you to taking on
so many different positions?
Was it
because you kind of sought variety,
or that was just the nature of the field?
And what you were doing.
Was really hard getting a permanent job?
Thing was,
I was trying to, to do folklore and,
because I had done an architectural thing
for my dissertation,
I kind of lie and say, you know, I'm
a sexual historian just to get a damn job.
And, sometimes that work sometimes didn't.
I'm not a historian.
So it was,
they write differently.
You have to write like a historian.
We write like
folklore is like, it's not a reverse.
So I had to do that.
I tried to get a job at Folklife Center
with the.
I don't know what happened with,
years ago, they were doing projects.
I don't know what they do anymore.
I just got on the.
They just weren't interested in
anything with, like,
the regular genres of folklore.
So I'm just trying to keep afloat.
How long did you continue to do
these jobs for?
Like, when did you retire officially?
I don't really consider
myself retired because the other thing
I learned to do was,
do research on archives.
So in DC, this is the place
for all kinds of archives, especially,
the main, governmental archives
and College Park, Maryland.
So what?
But I do a lot of research for people.
I I've done some government contracts
and environmental stuff,
sometimes on cultural stuff
or historic preservation.
The other
weird one was that I haven't done this now
for a couple of years,
but when the Soviet Union collapsed,
the Americans started
bringing in the balls
and other countries that. So,
I worked for a while as an interpreter
for the state park.
With the military from Warsaw.
And now we did a lot of shooting
and exploding
of stuff last.
Person.
So you're still taking on jobs even now?
You are still working?
Yeah. Okay. I can, you know, try.
It's just been really hard lately.
Because Covid, it's,
you know, with these idiots.
So thank God for the government.
I my next question was going to ask
how you keep busy,
but I guess a better question is
what do you do in your free time?
You know, sometimes I think of myself
more as a photographer.
I've been photographing
since I was a kid, and,
it's just a little different.
That and,
I mean, I had, for example, I'm
going through my dissertation
first because back then,
you know what you do?
You develop
the film, maybe
you print 1 or 2 photos
and that's it today.
Oh my God, you can scan them in.
Stuff you can do with a,
It's just magic, you know?
I just love it.
It's just the latest form,
you know, the travels.
Sometimes I think a lot of us,
I don't know, it
just, in this crazy era, it,
quiets me down, but.
Technology,
a certain certainly take taken like
many has come a long
way, has come a long way for sure.
Yeah.
Even in the time I've grown up,
I've seen so many changes as well.
So I can imagine what it's like for you
now to even live through more of that.
Those changes, and then myself.
I was just thinking
given in terms of the gear that.
But when you go out and still
oh my God, you know, and I think yeah,
it was during the time of the Gary Project
that I got my first
computer,
was a zenith computer.
Zenith was a big company,
made televisions and radios back, and
I don't know why they don't exist anymore,
but it was this big tower and the
keyboard, you know, there were no mice.
You had to learn keystrokes.
If you want to underline a word,
you had to put these keystrokes in front.
These are back.
And then all of that
gets somehow collapsed.
And that is thin laptop.
It was just stunning.
The difference that I was to so and so.
And I can't wait to talk to you
more about that in our next interview,
because a big part of my questions
is about the technology of the time
and the recording,
and you touched on it a bit,
but I look forward to talking to you
more about that.
Next time.
Is there anything else
you'd like to share or stories
or, thoughts
or your perspective
on anything that we've talked about?
I was kind of thinking about what
Dawson did
and what he wrote about and how,
I started reading the book
that I couldn't go through with it.
So subscriptions of interviews just,
But I,
I'm trying to think about his mindset.
He comes,
to an area
which is very different from where he was
before, like, okay,
but he has his old books,
but it's not like you're
I don't know about me.
You know, a lot of us
was sure of what he was collecting
and then then the
the Delta, I guess, of mainly blacks.
I don't I think
when he comes to Gary and it's so
like because he mentions this,
how folklore begins with the British,
you know,
and how they trying to collect this
from the folklore before it disappears.
And I think with that kind of mindset,
maybe he approaches Gary like he's
looking for some kind of folklore
of steel mills and stuff,
but it
almost sounds like he's
looking for an English version of this.
Because if there were any,
it would have been in Croatian
or in Slovak
or in Polish.
And he wasn't prepared to do any of that.
And sure, the team had some of them,
but I don't know if you noticed
that.
And the other thing
is, I mentioned the parishes.
Everybody had a parish.
They went to every school.
I mean,
I went to the Lithuanian parish, but
the Slovak
saint Emmerich's was actually closer.
I could have gone there, I guess,
but everybody had them.
I think those would have been
really fascinating places to,
discover and see what's going on
and some really bad stuff,
because I remember was,
not that far away it towards Broadway.
It was
either a Croatian or a Serbian church.
It caught on fire.
The firefighters
couldn't get to it because the ammunition
in the basement was going on,
and that's
how it's totally been moldering.
But back and so then Croatia and Serbia,
there were these leftist writers
that were killing each other,
and there was on Broadway,
the Main Street area was
it was a little office.
This guy shows up with a spotter
to print a little newsletter,
whatever he was printing.
And I don't know if he was Serbian killing
somebody walked in there
and shot them both.
So all his old country, crazy stuff
we saw, you know, in the wars
in the Balkans
was a sticky place.
And, and Gary and
the other thing
I was thinking of, too, how
a lot of
these
ethnic groups are living in their cocoons.
And I was exactly the same
with because of the Gary Project.
It opened my eyes to what was going on
in Gary in terms of these ethnic groups
that were just closed down,
not far from where my parents had a house
in Glen Park, just
I don't know how many blocks away.
I never knew it was the small
where the Macedonians met.
And it was incredible.
This place attracted all these young guys
who came to work in the mills,
are all bachelors and they went to,
you know, feel their culture.
So they went there to dance like circle,
which
I'll call.
And then they were just like
really into it, you know,
I got out of
the fucking bell and, and sing like dance.
And I feel so good.
And he can do that, you know,
go into this, for I think,
you didn't have a feeling for
ethnic America
or or aware of blacks.
So they were aware of Indians, but,
Not in the North America.
I mean, it was, new something new to them.
And I remember when I first got involved
and I looked at is there a zero folk in
the city says Jesus Christ?
Such is
so no, man.
We're just,
on some monkey really swinging from silks.
Silks that,
there was something about the ivory tower.
And back at the end of it,
like I said, they're really deep scholars,
sometimes ghosts of souls.
But when that's a holy, there's a
light.
So I thought.
And I'm sure that your perspective
is shaped by the fact that you lived
in this community.
You saw these people.
You knew where people like, frequented and
lived their lives,
for lack of a better phrase.
You know, even though they were Americans,
they also congregated in these.
Yeah, parish.
So whatever else?
And I think that's a wonderful place to.
And not because we can discuss more
about your impression of the great project
in our next interview.
If that works for you.
Maybe I'll go through the book more
and get some more ideas.
Thank you very much for that again.
And I'm going to end it here
if that's okay.
Yeah. So what?